[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me bring in albert breer he is the
senior nfl reporter lead content
strategist the monday morning
quarterback and he has been with us all
season long a nice round of applause for
albert breer
albert come on in
he's kind of positive yeah he did no he
was kind of uh soaking in the uh
spotlight there i'm just i get it no i
got it go ahead i'm just going we
couldn't get shifter we couldn't get
glazer we have albert breer
i'm glad i could stand in for those guys
i'm glad you made it too thank you it
was a grueling experience listen to
people asking what the drink choices
yeah um do you want to ask the poll
question albert therefore i can okay
do you have it i do have it i just have
like a lot of screens i have to click
the one that is the pro bowl is a fun
light-hearted exhibition or lame and
unwatchable is our pulse i think it's
somewhere in between because i think
it's being positioned to something more
than like a fun exhibition
like i don't like think the nfl should
put up any pretense that this is a real
game like i saw the official account
tweeting like oh look like they're
really playing defense out here it's
like no they aren't like no don't try to
fool us this isn't a real game you know
if i'm them and you know i like i like
the way it used to be when i was in
hawaii and i think that they should
really lean into
like you ever hear the stories about
peyton banning at the pro bowl
so like peyton manning treated this
almost like it was a convention for star
players and the stories about him like
sitting around the pool in hawaii like
so many guys like took something from
that right like he was like the mayor of
the pro bowl and because it was in
hawaii and it was hard to get to you
didn't have all these ancillary events
like they did like the skills
competition and that sort of stuff but
it didn't turn into this big circus
and i think like the nfl actually got
some benefit from that because star
players were getting to learn from
peyton manning as they were coming up
like hey here are some things that i
need to take into account as i go
forward in my career and so i think that
like if i was in charge i'd say we make
money off of everything else let's turn
this into a showcase for our star
players a convention for our star
players i think peyton manning had it
right and then peyton manning retires
they move it out of hawaii and now i
just think it's sort of become what it
is yeah but i i when does the official
or the the officials decide this is
going to be too in touch because they're
they're changing the rules mid-game yeah
i mean it's
i mean i like
i think that the players have an
agreement with each other we're going to
take care of each other out here and i
think the officials are in on that too
so
i mean i can't tell you that i watched
the whole thing yesterday because i
didn't i was flying but um you know like
i like i i like i do think that there's
an agreement between the players that
there's not going to be any heroes out
here like let's just all get out of this
healthy have some fun and i don't think
there's anything wrong with that i mean
i think players are way more conscious
now too
than they were 10 or 15 years ago of
like how their body is an asset like
you're not gonna see sean taylor laying
out a punter you know what i mean like
you're not gonna see that sort of play
in the pro bowl anymore
the miami dolphins found their head
coach
uh tell us more about him
the one thing you want to know about
mike mcdaniel is
like the people who have been around him
and that group of young coaches your
mcvays mike and matt lafleur all those
guys
i i don't think i'm talking out of
school dan when i say they regard him as
the smartest of all of them maybe
including kyle including sean
and i think the proof is that if you
look at kyle shanahan he's got this
group of coaches that sort of travel
with him from place to place there is
only one that has gone with him from
houston to washington to cleveland to
atlanta to san francisco that's been
with him every place
and that's mike mcdaniel and the reason
why is he's sort of the other side of
kyle's brain and it's even to the point
where you know my understanding in the
last few years in san francisco he had
that run game coordinator title right
and
like he'd basically be locked away
monday and tuesday you take care of the
run game i trust you with all of that
and kyle would go off with other
assistants and work on the passing game
so this is the guy who kyle shanahan
trusted most the question is going to be
like whether or not he can be
the front of the room leader
but i do think he's grown in that area
too where he's so comfortable in his own
skin that he doesn't need to get up
there and be like mike rabel you know
what i mean
i also wonder though when
it felt like when brian flores was being
fired that you were going to fire him to
hire jim harbaugh right normally you
fire somebody you have somebody in the
on deck circle yeah but i don't know
what happened because steven ross even
though we've talked about it hey i don't
want to take him from my alma mater but
if minnesota is going to take him from
your alma mater why don't you take him
for your own football team in south
florida and i thought that was the weird
thing about last week like i just i
think if he had had an offer
from minnesota the possibility existed
that he would go to them and say well
you know what now you're not taking me
from michigan anymore now you're taking
me from minnesota
um because i do think like i do think
jim harbaugh had and has had a desire to
get in the nfl this didn't just start
this year either i mean last year when
michigan put him in that position
where they were gonna force him to take
the pay cut he sniffed around the jets
he sniffed around the charges every team
that had an opening had gotten some
level of feelers from from jim harbaugh
like would you be interested in bringing
me in so he had shown that desire to get
to the nfl
i also think there's an element of this
he wanted michigan to sweat you know
what i mean like i mean
there's no one that holds a grudge like
jim harbaugh holds a grudge
and i i mean he actually is the grudge
because they cut his pants yeah yeah but
he held a grudge with the people that
made him take the pay cut and i think
for him like he didn't say anything but
he filed that away
and if
that like i'm not saying it's the
motivation for him doing what he did
over the last month but i think it's one
heck of a side benefit for him that like
those people that put him through that
last year that made him take that pay
cut and i don't think it's about the
money it's a pride thing yeah you know
making me you're gonna me you're gonna
embarrass me that way my alma mater is
gonna embarrass me that way and maybe he
deserved it but like the way that he
calculated calculated it was
like
you put me in this position you publicly
embarrassed me
i brought you to the playoff now i'm
gonna make you feel it a little bit
didn't he publicly embarrass them the
way michigan played
against ohio state i mean i was in
columbus a couple of years ago when they
could have put up 70 points on michigan
so i guess you could say you kind of put
us in this position
now would i have cut his pay in half no
yeah because knowing harbaugh's
personality i don't want to embarrass
him unless you know now he's
reinvigorated like i'll show you and
then they had this unbelievable year but
i i don't believe when he says hey this
is it i flirted one time with somebody
until that next offer the texans it
looks like are going to promote uh lovie
smith
what is going on here i i like i i think
that there was i mean a real desire to
look at josh mccown as the next head
coach
and he has no experience and i think
they understand the optics of it too and
i think that
my question is so there were some
real serious game management issues and
like i think one thing people get wrong
about the patriots people is thinking
like it's all about control and it's not
it's i think with the patriots people
what happens when they get matched with
people from other programs their
standards way up here and when that
standard isn't met it frustrates them it
angers them and i think there were some
things that slipped last year from a
detail standpoint in game where nick
casario made the decision i can't go
forward with david cauley as my head
coach and i understand that
why are you hiring his defensive
coordinator then like that's the thing
and i i think a huge part of this wound
up being optics
so like you know you've you've
eliminated everybody with three
candidates you called jonathan gannon on
saturday called again and on saturday
told him he's out now you're down to
josh mccown and brian and brian flores
and can you hire brian flores when he's
suing the league i'd argue it'd be a
bold move and they should have tried to
do that
um
you know i think that they could turn i
think they should turn around and maybe
look at a gerard mayor who understands
the program
it just feels like they're doing
something that maybe is a safe thing
right now which i mean who's to say
we're not going to be back here a year
from now that's true albert breer the
monday morning quarterback joining us
here
in our la studios we stand on the
precipice of having more
african-americans on the united states
supreme court than as head coaches in
the national football league that's dr
harry edwards civil rights activist
telling that to the new york times
uh the saints
is eric the enemy going to get a job
no i don't think this in this case what
are we missing here
so i mean i don't think it's that
uncommon we've seen it before like pete
carmichael the offensive coordinator of
the saints a really good coach
like just nfl teams didn't project him
to be a head coach and he's been the
offensive coordinator for some really
good offenses in new orleans for what
the last 12 years
and so sometimes this happens and
i you know i think like people pinning
all of the like using like
airbnb who i think's a good coach like
using him to kind of explain everything
that's wrong with the system
i i think has made it so it's a little
harder for teams to
look past that and go why are we looking
at gerard mayo why aren't we looking at
damiko ryan's why aren't we looking at
leslie frazier why are we there's there
are a lot of good candidates out there
and i think focusing too much on one guy
sort of exacerbates the problem because
now it's like okay well we feel like we
have to bring him in now you literally
are checking a box instead of like doing
the real investigation figuring out like
hey rahim morris did a heck of a job in
l.a he's been a head coach before but
give him a shot tomiko ryan's trod mayo
two examples of ex players like mike
frable that project to be really good
head coaches um yeah i think focusing
too much on the enemy and again i think
eric's a good coach i think can make the
problem worse
uh question about the super bowl it
feels like matthew stafford wins the
super bowl he's going to go the hall of
fame
depending on how well he plays but
it's almost like he and philip rivers
are similar that you know
although rivers more successful in the
postseason but they're stat guys if joe
burrow wins a super bowl see now all of
a sudden now you're halfway to the hall
of fame yeah and you're the next mahomes
right so
uh what anger do you love the most
i like the idea that burrow
stylistically and i covered brady when
he was young stylistically he's the
closest thing to tom brady to come into
the league since brady was young um but
more athletic more athletic but the
accuracy the pocket movement and as much
as anything else i think it's like the
ability to galvanize and change a place
and this isn't the first time we've seen
it either like i think i've said this to
you before but like when he was at lsu
what was lsu for all those years
tough defense when they were competent
and on an offense and that wasn't always
it was like a beauchem beckler three
yards in a cloud of dust type of offense
and he gets in there what happens he
changed everything right and so i think
the same thing's happening in cincinnati
so that's the ability to sort of
galvanize an entire place and change a
place which brady could do
and then it's in the biggest moments
flatline like he's an intense competitor
but in the biggest moments when guys
walk into the huddle with him total
flatline and that's why i think in a
spot like this
i mean god if they if the bengals can
just get it into the final five minutes
of the game i think it's tough to bet
against burrow
i brought this up when brady announced
he was retiring like what is next
because these guys always got to fill
that void and i didn't know if you could
see brady owning a team
i didn't see him as a broadcaster even
though if i'm amazon
i just throw out 25 million dollars a
year yeah what's 25 to amazon uh what
are you having known tom for a long time
what what do you think quenches that
thirst uh you know i think that there's
i think he's been fearful of this for a
while like what this is going to be like
because i think he knows as competitive
as he is there's going to be nothing
that can replace what he's about to walk
away from um and i think that's part of
what kept him in it to be honest with
you is like the fear of like what's it
going to be like when i don't have that
outlet anymore you know i do think like
a big part of it for him
is all this knowledge he's built up and
like kind of like the proprietary um
proprietary advantage that he's had over
everybody else
it's finding a way now to to give that
to other people you know and i and i
think
you know that's what tb12 is about like
i like i think like i wouldn't surprise
me if he started helping young
quarterbacks um he had people in his
life that were really important in his
life guys like you know tom martinez who
is you know whose private private
quarterback coach when he was young
um tom house obviously more recently um
that made a huge impact on alex guerrero
that
like i think really were game changers
for him and i think like the idea that
he could make a business out of being
that sort of game changer i think
appeals to him which is what tb12 was
when he launched it final question
could you beat up adam schefter
i get the height advantage i got reached
yes you do
that sounds like a yes to me guys
no comment let's bring out adam schefter
here he comes
glazer you have no shot with oh clay's
would be tough yeah i have reach on him
too but i think he might i think he
might might have me there uh locking
four uh yeah i'm gonna take you yeah i
think i'd i think you could take that
one how about jeff darlington
jeff's pretty like i don't know i think
jeff's pretty so like i think i think
all you would have to do is muddy the
fight up a little bit
thanks for all your uh help this year
absolutely contributions you always make
us smarter every time you're on uh
you might want to thank me too since i
had i said thank you well man it didn't
feel my pleasure i said my pleasure
thank you for having me i appreciate it
i mean you could have started it but hey
before i you know we end this i'd just
like to say thank you for boosting my
career i mean little things oh thank you
working with the legend
try it again next time
uh hey thank you have a great week okay
i'll kiss the ring after we get on okay
that's fine uh he's albert breer the uh
senior nfl reporter league content
strategies monday morning
even the the back room guys aren't
really applauding here can we try that
one more time for albert breer
that's pretty good thanks guys
thank you dan oh thank you you're
welcome albert play of the day's up next